listening to film courage women
and Kerry Wood I'm la talk radio
today's show is brought to you by the no
budget film school which presents its
famed today no budget filmmaking
immersion in Los Angeles may 30th and
31st specifically designed for the no
budget filmmaker whether working with a
budget of 200 thousand dollars or two
thousand dollars the lessons tools and
techniques gained will maximize very
limited resources and minimize critical
errors that can do other wise worthy
projects producer Mark Stoller off
former principal IFC's next wave films
and guest experts teach the specific
methods models and priorities of
micro-budget filmmaking and this
one-of-a-kind class for more information
go ahead and register and visit w WN 0
budget film school calm